straight away a sign things aren't
entirely back to normal as Prince
Charles showed off his replacement for a
handshake this was a really important
first chance to say thank you face to
face to NHS staff even from two meters
apart it's been a marvelous opportunity
just to have a chance of seeing people
who had never been doing so much on the
literally on the front line and having
to enjoy an awful lot of stress or
strain in their wonderful way how they
do it I don't know the Duchess of
Cornwall was keen to hear how
coronavirus had personally affected them
at the Gloucestershire Royal Hospital
and people have gone above and beyond
before therefore went holidays weekend's
family time it's been horrendous and
especially seeing colleagues being
poorly as has been as been awful but but
really everyone's done so well and
worked together so well as well as
reflect on something positive that's
come from the pandemic done the most
remarkable things I mean the way they've
looked after people the way they've sort
of kept control of the whole thing you
know it's a question of not panicking
getting on with it and I think they are
Britain at its best
in Norfolk Prince William was also out
having his temperature taken another
first for a royal engagement as he
arrived to check up on how paramedics
are coping this is how all engagements
are going to be for now much more
low-key no big crowds but it is the
royal family again doing what they do
best during difficult times which is
getting out and saying thank you to
those who deserve it they know they need
to be seen to be working within those
government guidelines but just like the
rest of us
there are things that they miss we on on
Mills Sky News in Qinglin